hello guys it's Greg it's John so we're
here today to do the movie news of the
week on May 7th through May 4 change 27
times here we go if you're watching this
on patreon it's the video podcast where
you can see us talking moving and doing
what we're doing right now you can see
that thing I just did was just for you
we're experimenting and we were we've
been asked by a lot of comments over the
past couple years to do more podcasts
we're trying to answer a few more you
know give you a little more of a comment
and wanted over the past couple years
covered that versus fine
we like John I was always like to
contagion experiment with stuff on the
channel and so if you're listening to
this on YouTube it's a podcast format
audio only so you're missing out on a
cool video stuff like this you can't see
us doing this kind of stuff I see the
raver move you still want to do that oh
yeah this jump it took john and i weeks
to learn how to do this everyone up
everybody tries that does this people on
youtube can't see overdoing you can have
the ones on the stream below you guys
check out the bay tree i don't know what
the hell's going on right now
battery's already dying this podcasts
are not so great then we're gonna switch
out the battery really quick okay you
want to plug that one in so we all right
just switched out the battery we just
wanted to also make a quick announcement
that we recently want some t-shirts
that's right shop top Spreadshirt comp
slash the real rejects you can go check
out our designs over there got some
t-shirts and iphone cases and those
people have some iPhone type of design
of a cell phone these days yeah yeah and
what's just one of your burner phones we
have a case for that too and and also
yeah go check out our
our designs there and if you're on
patreon one of the reward tiers is you
can get an autograph once sent to you so
Rose ahora really watching this video
what may the end of May rolls around
them will receive our shirts will be
mailing you at an autograph one because
you received that shirt as a reward
anyway let's hop into the movie leaders
of the week we don't have a lot of movie
needs to cover today but we got a few
hey John what do you do
Judge Dredd is coming to TV Pape Oh Oh
finally it's gonna be called Judge Dredd
megacity one okay here is what the judge
dredd world is in case you guys haven't
seen dread or Judge Dredd or I think
there was an animated thing or read the
comics it's a feature set story
following a team of cops who act as
judge Jude executioner
when dealing with the challenges of the
22nd century east coast of the US and
overcrowded crime ridden niggle apollo
megalopolis megalith palace expect to
see stories echoing modern troubles like
domestic terrorism and the tensions
between the ultra rich and the
disenfranchised oh [ __ ] okay I think
this is a brilliant idea it might be an
expensive ass show yeah sorry
one pricey TV show to make but Judge
Dredd you know that's a that's a guilty
pleasure in mind uh the woman Stallone
and Rob Schneider yeah well I think
that's a really enjoyable film I will
gladly that's other than the theaters I
owned it growing up and even when I
watched it today I'm like yeah corny and
pretty awful but I still really enjoy it
Dredd with Karl Urban was a badass film
that not a lot of people tuned in for
Alex Garland right that movie I do think
so and Circe was in it
right is the villain right yeah I didn't
either these movies why people I know
John you call it you and your hipster
mentality I wanted to see Dredd who the
ladders [ __ ] went red 3d was coming
out like I saw the trailer I was like
this looks so amazing and everybody else
around me was like it was really really
shitty and that what opening weekend can
they all came back they were like there
are so many good idea and yeah yeah -
Dredd 3d was really really cool
the thing about Judge Dredd I feel this
way I feel like most comic-book stories
probably work better in a television
medium if they could afford it if it has
left it that's the only problem with
something like Judge Dredd is but I
think you can definitely bring this to
television in try to AMC - Bruce yeah
yeah even though they don't seem like
this is really like to say great but it
doesn't belong to a network yet it's
being developed by rebellion and I am
global they're both independent studios
that are developing the show applying
ten episodes and Judge Dredd is a is one
of those world building kind of stories
that I think would really work in a
television format and you know because
that's one of the things about Judge
Dredd that's fascinating to me like
they're both action films the ones that
came out as they should be they should
have those elements in there but there's
always this crazy extra room that you
could have for awesome world building
this is like a post-apocalyptic kind of
future in the East Coast Territory and
the whole idea of the judges that walk
the streets of cops are also judges you
know sending giving up sentences on the
street I think that's really neat and
the thing is it is a very futuristic
kind of world so I am wondering what is
the look they'll be going for in the TV
show because the movies are you know
they're capturing the future pretty damn
well like they are futuristic films and
they needed big-budget some really
what the images I saw I saw the trailers
for dread and I saw at least one fight
scene and what I ate what drew me in
about what I saw was that it did look
like distinctly the future but also like
you know the fighting I saw at least
took place in kind of a dingy building
and I really like our versions of the
future they're like that like looper add
that to words like yeah it's definitely
not now but it also is still shitty
stuff er yeah yeah yeah I think what's
that new Jason Momoa film into the
balance into the yon family in the
balance the bad batch the bad back aah
oh and I bet is that the bad batch I
imagined kind of that kind of dystopian
apocalyptic world you know just a little
bit more in just winning a city yeah as
a city version of this yeah but I mean
just look at the the world description
that we just read off of here
overcrowded crime ridden is legit dark
early it's a world III enjoy the comic
book shows I'm already watching as I
watched the flash era i watch all the
MCU shows and I think the comic book
world
I think comic books are there is a whole
world to them even if they take place in
a real world like daredevil takes place
in house kitchen with all the MCU shows
on Netflix take place in New York but in
there in itself is its own world its own
set of rules and I feel like gesture ed
would probably find the proper
adaptation I mean it took what's three
Punisher movies and they finally bring
in the television and it worked with
like this is it this is the perfect
punishment yet right here and I could
see Judge Dredd be the same argument in
the same case for a totally different
kind of world so I think to read could
totally work for television now now it
is my man gonna do it it so loud yeah
yeah he just did guardians to now's the
time the loan should do it at least
alone she's not [ __ ] Carl or ever hear
even see his [ __ ] ass face in that man
that carbon was this [ __ ]
and that lect is so cool because I've
always admired just how much he seems to
really like that seems like his Deadpool
it seems like he really wants to do
Dredd stuff and he's really dedicated
like keeping the mask on and looking at
it right and and so like I think it
would be friggin awesome
he was involved with this I think it
would be [ __ ] a [ __ ] granite
podcast going on YouTube but who cares a
video on patreon so you can see us
swearing and not worry though it doesn't
matter ever since we put on that
restricted mode video I've still been
doing really good cuz I'm like this is
definitely going on restricting another
big deal about how we're gonna cut back
I heard especially have not really been
cutting back in it if it doesn't make it
difference even if it's not in
restricted Meg anyway let's move on to
the next story paintball alright Jason
Blum says that split tool having more
traditional budget cease wit had a
budget of nine million euros 275 million
dollars dollars dollars what a wow
that's the machinery that's one of the
you know other 15 personalities we
didn't see Kevin do excellent
I'm a mobile producer from tank sit and
unbreakable which is a 2000 film yeah
had a budget 75 million oh boy and gross
248 million dollars worldwide so in my
notes I put down the question where will
the budget me with having stars like
Bruce Willis
Sam Jackson James McAvoy on - Taylor joy
all being in this movie cuz I'm Chad
Joy's an ass for a budget up she's gonna
ask for a woman oh yeah race it's a race
you know this on Mother's Day I got
pretty girl a girl I can you breathe
alright so problem we filming zubi zubi
huge day because y'all need me yeah yeah
totally compensate be fairly I mean it's
funny cuz split made more way more money
it profited and not only did it make
more money because it's like okay I'm
break cool made like 25 million dollars
inflation bro but there's also the
inflation of factoring it's also the
fact that the production budget of split
was like you know sixty million dollars
less than the 101 breakable so I'm I am
I'm rather curious about what will the
budget because Blum House is producing
this in and Blum house was known for low
budget films yeah you would know you
know some people at blonde house John
well yeah and I think our biggest budget
things have been yeah I think other
studios have invested in yeah yeah oh
yeah when they like co-produced by
travursel or something when when
Paranormal Activity five the last
paranormal activity with like 20 million
dollars something like that like I think
I think there was help with 10 oh yeah
no no I don't really know they're out
there probably was I dig Paravel roaming
through out of money so I'm curious as
to where the budget will actually lie
cut it you know Bruce Willis he didn't
even sign on for another Expendables
movie because you wanted a million extra
dollars for that one oh and that's not
on you in a movie he gives a [ __ ] oh
baby is that my poem Bruce Willis but
funny enough I feel like if Bruce was
actually cared about the role I feel
like he might be willing to take a
slight pay like not now I feel like he
has to get paid this much money to do it
cuz I've gotta keep it give enough of a
[ __ ] about them or maybe who just want
to do it yeah cuz he was amazing and
unbreakable he's amazing in that film
and hey and he worked together and I
Shama on the sixth sense another film
where he's incredible in that it so I
feel like Bruce Willis he doesn't give a
[ __ ] about the action films I'll break
this this new glass movie is not going
to be an action film I hope not yeah it
is not going to be there's not I hope
there's not going to be a sky portal no
I'm going to destroy all of Baltimore
it's the it's true it's cool to me
because you know when I look at
unbreakable and split the two kind of
act
scenes in the movie you know and I'm
breakable when he's like feeling
everyone without their permission yeah
at the train station and then he goes
the guys how and strangles a guy to
death yeah that's like the only action
that is yeah that's like a fight but
it's not even I would call it a [ __ ]
right I'm not funny that's a scary scene
and then the Kevin and I'm breakable
turning into the Beast and that was kind
of action as sort o to send my lunch or
when Tonya Taylor joy with the shotgun
and he's crawling and stuff and I don't
imagine this film will have that much it
will have action in it but it mayn't
British bullets and Sam Jackson alone
you got to pay those guys some serious
money to get them involved yeah James
McAvoy being really high caliber high
profile actor now and on a sailor Joyce
career really rising an M night
Shyamalan probably wanting a little more
money now that he's back on in the
market it's gonna be expensive to get
everybody to agree I feel like you got
to keep it still reasonably a low budget
because I think Shyamalan gets carried
away with big budgets yeah I'm actually
surprised to find the first movie cost
so much I thought it cost considerably
less than 75 million well Bruce Willis
is also way bigger at the time and so
it's a time Jackson was still he's still
pretty here Sam Jackson and that black
[ __ ] on the line is just coming off the
sixth sense the production budget will
be somewhere up near nine like yeah
above nine million at least I guess like
a twenty five thirty million dollar
budget thank you yeah I can get yes a
little 144 me enough me maybe I think
that'd be I think I just fine though
what is the middle ground between nine
million and seventy five million if I
find that budget we can pay all the rest
of you from what's left
yeah because I don't know I'm really
hoping I'm hoping the budget doesn't
affect how on board all these actors are
yeah because what's making this so
exciting is the characters crossing over
with each other and you're going to want
that pure investment because now when
you watch them break them all the
performances they're from Sam Jackson
and Bruce Willis or phenomenal and same
thing with James McAvoy on Taylor joy
and split again I know nothing
the money dealings but I feel like if
that's an issue and that at that point
there are probably a million other
people with big wads feeling they're all
we want to help out with this very we'll
get it done please we're doing good
what you see on sniff lodge we will do
it I just have Bruce Willis is asleep in
the film and Sam Jackson's louder yeah
yeah this [ __ ] glass this
[ __ ] split personality what
happened to the glass character Saxon
dude why does the principal's care about
his mission in this ring why is James
McAvoy the only good ones I can enjoy
really certain purposes what you
revisited
well I'm sailor joins me like the only
one who ended off on a note of where is
very character gonna go who could you
know yeah that yeah is like I didn't
know there was so much more I wanted to
know about her after that movie yeah
like wait a minute like because they
develop they give you that whole like
subplot where they're developing her
character in the flashback like yeah
that's kind of a big story once it all
wraps up and then yeah the movie just
kind of ends here like one of you yes
and if you re back to her stepfather
maybe she kills her start off with her
stepfather being killed or maybe she's
somebody very different than who we
think she is like well what I think it
for this one is we need at least two
more villains maybe introduce another
cool little protagonist character but
they're all going to work together I
just I just needed to be even bigger as
it should be if we're trying to happen
they should do it all great versus
movies they're good let's talk about
this one john martin scorsese says the
Irish Man Irishman will be different
from Goodfellas all right here's a
long-ass quote from Martin Scorsese
who's one of her more laid-back moving
could you have already impression and
how I have no idea no I don't know how
to do it I think this is different I
think it is
I meant they are you know your photos in
casino have a certain style that I
created for them it's on the page and
the script actually putting Goodfellas
together was almost like an afterthought
at times I was kind of rushing I felt
like I already done it because I played
out in terms of the cameras the editing
and that sort of thing
Dadda Dadda Dadda okay the people are
also older in the irishman it's
certainly more about looking back a
retrospective so to speak of a man's
life and the choices these had to make
what makes a person this way what makes
them become a professional killer it's
about love betrayal remorse and the
sadness and tragedy ultimately of a life
led that way it's about mercy too I
don't know if there'll be any of that in
the picture yet there might be why would
you say all those things and then say
could I begin the belt sir I think he
means there's a good Phyllis stylist
other good foe stuff well I'm glad he's
not just I mean don't get me wrong
that's what I hope you mean but does
that makes more sense Goodfellas is but
like easily one of my favorite films of
all time it's it's one of the films I've
seen I like too many times to count
yeah I see have way too many times yeah
Goodfellas is great I just thought again
recently and I forgot how much I enjoyed
yeah yeah how much how how much is going
on inside of it you know and Casino is
like the companion piece to it it feels
like like oh yeah this is definitely I
know the Goodfellas kind of move hey hey
that was the same director similar
Jasmine and I like both Goodfellas and
Casino but the Irishman yeah I know
they're going to do some D aging stuff
with flashbacks but yeah I mean I'm glad
sources like guys we're all like senior
citizens now yeah yeah me directing
Pacino De Niro Pesci Keitel we're all
old we're not going to do the rise of
the gangster movie much of like fun and
coke and acylated yeah yeah whacking
dudes get
inside if anything to me you didn't see
Godfather three did you know not all of
us seen flashes of it
well Godfather three I thought has a
rather interesting element to because it
takes place where Michael Corleone he's
way older now okay more they like older
than however older he was that Al Pacino
actually was at the time like they did
even though a long time had passed
they made him a lot older still and it
was a lot about you know where he's come
since then and a lot of guilts a lot of
remorse a lot of who is who he's become
along the way and a lot of looking back
at like this sounds like this could be a
better version of what Godfather three
was trying to do okay in terms of okay
or focus on these over kind of mobster
characters with you know these legendary
actors in there and I don't know I feel
like stories that that we saw that a lot
of us are really drawn to these days or
characters who have a mysterious past
where when you see a character on screen
you could feel there's a whole history
behind them full of all kinds of
criminal activities well you can imagine
the challenge to of a movie like that
where like maybe you get to you're
getting to know this guy in the later
years of his life and then we start
flashing back to review things that he's
done in your little bets I'm going to be
challenging to the protagonists of your
dad you know and I feel like mob films
yeah and it tells the casino certainly
have the element of here's how I became
a gangster here's my rise now here's my
fall and I feel like if you're if you're
taking these actors making them the
stars of this specific tale and I don't
know the book that it's based on I
haven't read it I like the I like that
he's specifically going out of his way
to say this isn't going to be another
Goodfellows 2.0 this is going to be a
different kind of stuff go Scorsese to
matured as a director oh yeah and even
though he can still make you know those
[ __ ] fast-paced highly edited kinetic
kind of films like the parted which
wasn't that long ago or even shutter
island which was right after that yeah I
am interested to see how he does this I
feel like this could be sort of his the
good version of Godfather three years
Once Upon a Time in America the type of
film maybe maybe not as much as he
always works enough actually I feel like
it's films have this certain kind of
even like his slower ones are kind of
you may have a rhythm yeah like Silence
is one of them definitely slower films
but it does have a river but it doesn't
I wouldn't say it's like dull an
assassin hit you now I really liked I
was a lot actually that who that was one
where I saw it I was like wow like this
guy still got it like he's still a
really good filmmaker so and and that's
a that's a film film you know yeah
that's not there's a there's a vast
difference to me between like Hugo and
silence you know in terms of what parts
of the spectrum he's working on and
that's what's really exciting to me
about this is like I think it's a really
cool opportunity just for us as an
audience to see this guy come back to a
genre to the crime genre that he has had
like a stamp on these always been a part
of and now he can you know bring his new
perspective to it yeah and so like stuff
like silence mixed in with like the
style of silence it's very contemplative
and it's very kind of philosophical and
so it's very human I feel like he can
borrow from those colors it at least if
you're to believe the quote it sounds
like he's going to borrow from shades of
that and Mick down with the crime the
stories we know so welcome yeah it seems
like he's taking the approach of the
emotional turmoil when you get to a
certain point in your life and live
leading a life as like a gangster well
each of these movie seems like it's
about what life is like right now with
about her lifestyle yeah so I think this
would be cool like this really I'm
excited for it you know I I'm really
hoping they do some limited release and
the theaters yeah like at an arc light
or Egyptian theater or something where
you where you can see it for the weekend
with home
Tremont yeah so I'm so glad okay it's
going to be on Netflix cool it he's
probably going to be able to make the
exact movie he wants to make is going
directly to Netflix he has nothing to
lose here because everyone's gonna see
the cast but your source age is doing it
is on Netflix are all gonna tune in to
watch the damn thing so you know be cool
though and if Netflix drop some coin and
got some prints made now be cool I
projected it places Oh that'd be really
cool I hope so cuz then like cuz you
know Scorsese's like a respected
filmmaker like that would be like a
unique them thing for them to do be like
see ya the real world - ah your favorite
director let's go Doug lemonade
our reveals the edge of tomorrow - teil
here I'm quoting him here we have an
amazing story it's incredible way better
than the first film and I obviously
loved the first film are you're fit I'll
guys it will be called limbs I repeat
and repeat Tom Cruise is excited about
it and Emily Blunt is excited about it
the big question is just when will do it
but it's not an if it's a one he goes on
to say I've had some radical ideas about
how to make a sequel that would interest
me in the same way that I had ideas
about how I could make an independent
film and then swingers came along and it
was like AHA that's the perfect movie
for me to test these ideas out on I had
these intellectual ideas on how you
should make a sequel that are unlike how
anybody else makes a sequel and the
script this script and this idea fit
perfectly into that idea so it's gonna
revolutionize how people make sequel and
again that's why I try to do things like
invisible that are just the revolutions
sort of built into the idea it's more
heresy in the film world for me to pitch
things there's sort of understa I'm
really wondering what Valley is talking
about I mean first off you're saying
like
I have no idea is what edge of tomorrow
- is going to be like because it's like
telling someone you're gonna make
Groundhog Day jitter Google what is your
movie gonna be about exactly you're
repeating the same day again because the
film's called live die repeat and repeat
and he's saying he's making a sequel
that's way unlike anybody else those
sequels but your films called live die
repeat and repeat so it sounds like
you're just repeating something I don't
know I like it's weird like it's a weird
title but I also kind of like it I mean
don't get me wrong
edge of tomorrow that year that was my
favorite movie that year I listed it a
mine in my top 10 list that was my
favorite movie that year I got some crap
for that cuz you know who some
oscar-nominated films I could've made
that number one spot for me good but I
really liked it they wanted it call I
mean first off I think the book is the
graphic novels call all you need is kill
yes and then they called it then they
were going to call it live die repeat
then they call the edge of tomorrow then
when they release it on DVD they called
it live die repeat edge of tomorrow or
it was reverse edge of tomorrow live die
repeat a lot of people thought it was
called live die and repeat from the
billboard yeah yeah I mean I I think
that's a great tagline I think it's a
cool title honestly really I lived every
edge of tomorrow is a catch you're more
marketable title yeah but I just if
you're asking me I just think live diver
be cool however if you're going from
edge of tomorrow to live die repeat and
repeat that's cool because I get really
tired of the subtitle game well Willy
Willy in Viviani yeah he posted on
Facebook recently he had created is
called why is he called live die repeat
and repeat when the first one's not
called of die repeat title me I feel
like they're taking advantage of how
muddy that water is but that could just
be me yeah cuz like I remember what end
of tomorrow was coming out there was
confusion and there was
talk of the title yeah I don't know to
me
edges tomorrow and while that mother is
a world in there that I enter the
yesterday I think well I think there is
a world in there that could totally be
explored with additional installments
yeah I I'm conflicted about being on
board with a sequel because I do love
the movie but it seems more like this is
a perfect one movie only yeah I had a
situation for me and I'm kind of
surprised getting Greenland for a sequel
because I looked at the numbers and the
movie costs a hundred seventy eight
million dollars for its production
budget that's just as budget then it
only grows two hundred million dollars
domestically if you're watching in the
u.s. words the domestic two hundred
seventy million dollars in the foreign
markets okay that's really not a whole
lot of profit the movie made for such an
expensive asked film yeah and I I don't
feel because I feel like the only Tom
Cruise movies that perform ridiculously
well are the Mission Impossible films
every other Tom Cruise film was like
make some money yeah that's not there's
a lot of breaks that between them would
not much talk about any other future
installments with Tom Cruise flicks is
an admission of possible movies are the
one franchise where after Neopost crazy
Scientology stuff where people oh yeah
we're just looking for a Mission
Possible begin yeah yeah and ed to
tomorrow wasn't marketed that well I
wasn't even really looking forward to
seeing it and then I watched it and I
loved it I thought it was an incredible
piece of cinema
III don't know I mean it for him to say
he I'm more suspicious about this as
Doug Liman is a great filmmaker he's
done some really entertaining films I'll
save that but the boy he wants the
Bourne franchise but it's not the best
board
no anyway really entertaining films like
swingers but a lot of people really
credit the performances and the script
by Jon Favreau / Doug Liman awesome
direction get a lot of people get that
movie confused
yeah I'm not thinking about our current
good every day I do that all the time
because it's built for Lego Jon Favreau
so John Barrowman and he didn't miss her
mrs. Smith which is one of my favorite
type of romantic comedies honestly I
think I love that movie it's really
enjoyable I think he makes incredibly
entertaining and jumper was a film that
a lot of people didn't like he had an
idea for a whole franchise for that
obviously didn't pan out I personally
thought it was a really entertaining
film could have been better I so thought
it was really entertaining doug liman
super always seems unique if nothing
else yeah and I one thing that said to
me about edge of tomorrow was this is
more than just entertaining and this is
a magical film but yeah it was only film
I've seen where I'm like this is a
magical film that close second would be
Bourne Identity I think but then I felt
Bourne films became really defined
wandering drastic over yeah but here
when it comes to edge of time just but
sharing the title here another to talk
about unique sequel I don't know maybe
I'm not creative enough to let my mind
go down a path they could be like
lawyers how it's a totally different
kind of Z cool yeah well you know yeah
because the part of what made edge
tomorrow such a big sell with the
gimmick of repeating the same day over
and over again and if you're do and it
sounds like with your title you're doing
that again and it may be on a different
day it's probably going to be kind of
similar maybe I don't know I mean that
this is a weird announcement to like as
much as I do think like in my own little
john vacuum like I think is the cool
title just because like I'm imagining
being in a blockbuster it has a boy and
seeing like those two together be like
yeah like I just like when they do that
with titled but yeah this is a anytime I
just get uptight whenever you go
back to a movie that surprised me with
how good it wasn't like how many things
it had on its mind and so yeah he sounds
really amped about this he sounds like
so excited about this and so like I'm
definitely intrigued but I yeah I have
no idea what to expect and with a movie
that expensive I don't know how how much
I can I can take his word on faith alone
like how much this is going to get out
of your way I mean Tom Cruise if he
believes in you enough you could
probably make that happen to maybe what
founders wanted he's been wanting a
sequel for a lot and I just read
something like a month or two ago about
how they Doug Liman is doing like
Justice League dark and the producers
were like we got Doug because we were
like Doug we want you to done why
minissha I want you to make it weird as
hell and like I didn't even know that
was his reputation we're going to let
you make these weirder than impossible
and so I'm intrigued yeah like I don't
believe it's impossible and and there's
a part of me that really hopes he's
right
because if they brought our med room
tomorrow sequel that just rearranged my
brain for me like that would be so cool
but you know he's setting the bar he's
really high he is I think he might be
and the first set I think that's where
the the deccan skepticism comes in is
because of how high he's setting the bar
I mean yeah he's dating like way better
than the first film like what unlike how
anybody else
this script imperfectly that that ideas
revolutionize how people make sequels
I'm like whoa what exactly are you
saying here careful please show us first
yeah when I tell you yeah I don't know
hey man you know you can't blame people
my hear us and go just wait for the
movie but I think in this day and age so
can I have a healthy bit of skepticism
when it comes to things and people in
Hollywood sick especially when they're
really trying to make sure that you get
the
Greenwood yeah edge of tomorrow doug
liman I hope this is all true I hope
it's all true
knowing the movie industry I'm just a
little worried who's off hey Greg guess
what yes sir there is a Hellboy remake
in the works
oh I really hope gilma del Toro's not
doing it and I hope Rob Perlman gets his
ass out of that chair
great we're hoping that Guillermo del
Toro is not involved in this and Ron
Perlman will not be playing hell boy
your luck hollyford a god yes that's all
I wanted stranger things start David
Harbor will be playing Hellboy this oh
my God he's hot right now
is he the sheriff he's the sheriff oh
boy he's will is working out so hard -
ed gonna shoot everything in force
perspective - good we great I'll just
film will be directed there's a kicker
Qi train you ready all right Emile
Marshall director of the descent
director of doomsday several episodes of
Game of Thrones where we'll film Dog
Soldiers he is going to be making this
film
he's also directing a loss in the space
reboot for Netflix what yeah I'm gonna
show her a film and a show okay uh I'll
wait and see
I interesting but here's a screenwriter
Andrew Cosby one of the illegitimate
children of Bill Cosby set this is a
darker more gruesome version of Hellboy
Neel said from the very beginning he
wanted to walk a Razors Edge between
horror and comic book movie which was a
music to my ears
because that's what I was shooting for
the script and precisely what Mignola
does so well with the comics well um
that's cool with me because the Hellboy
movies are you know they hone in more on
from what I've never read the comics but
from people I know that I've read the
comics and then they we see the movies
or like it's definitely careful
Toros take on Yammer it definitely plays
up the fantasy side a lot which I can
see well and it's not as much of a
disappointment to me as as in sam raimi
not getting to do his spider-man 4
because you know spider-man was such a
major like global worldwide hit and the
first two were phenomenal and he gets
one bad movie to then go through so well
the next one
Hellboy films I felt a very dedicated
fan base to the movies and even though
once you thought it was different from
the comics still really enjoyed the
films and bottom line is del Toro was
incredibly passionate about Hellboy and
he's are wanting to make his Hellboy 3
and complete his trilogy for ages now as
a matter of fact I was on movie fight
one time in my life I got one point in
movie fights and that's when I argued
for what film should do mozilla Toro
direct next I argued Hellboy 3 because a
man with that much passion who's
dedicated this much time into Hellboy 1
and 2 yes and Ron Perlman who that's one
of his baby roles you know he loves that
character so much I felt they needed to
complete their Hellboy trilogy I did -
yeah I still kind of feel that I do I do
yeah I definitely feel that way I
although I feel I feel that way and at
the same time I am interested in this
yeah well because every other day the
other Hellboy movies didn't really make
much money they did it let's think about
what you said on into tomorrow's like
that's the idea I got from those is like
they think may just enough to justify
existing and to make every student go
yeah which I feel that it happens a lot
with Guillermo del Toro I'm not that I
mean this director likes to dabble in
horror for sure me made the descent
doomsday he's working dog soldiers Dog
Soldiers worked on the Hannibal show
I've heard he's made some very pivotal
episodes for Game of Thrones yeah so as
there you know if I deal with fantasy
any notes I deal with horror which is
perfect for Hellboy
and even though del Toro is great with
horror Hellboy doesn't really have the
del Toro horror elements he had all the
fantasy action elements yeah and there's
like some some creepy imagery yeah so
and there's some great effect that's
that's one thing I don't want the movie
this reboot
yes to das DVD that is CGI everything
because there's some great practical
effects in the Hellboy movies yeah that
del Toro brought select they were his
version but it's still great practical
designs of creatures and I wouldn't hate
it if the reboot doesn't do that that's
one thing I'm like I'm hoping they sync
inspiration from and make it practical
effects if they come out with David
Harbour looking like the Beast and
Beauty and the Beast where it's a cross
between CGI and practical but you're not
sure there is any practical at all to
make you CGI yes I would be very upset
because you watch the ROM pearl and
you're like real attic rondell boy yeah
yeah that's yeah that's and casting
David Harbour you you said that why he's
real hot right now and and that's
something that always were ever since
night-night marinelle most Riga remained
that has started to worry me because
when the cast jakiro heylia's Friday I
was like that's a cool idea I could have
and did not go well at all even though I
think he's a good actor of seeing good
things too and so I think the little
parts of his performance in stranger
things I've seen I like him I think
David Harvard will kick ass as hell boy
well ma yeah I think you'll be I'm not
sure he'll be as much of a signature for
trail or voice as Ron Perlman is yeah
I've seen a few of David harbors worse
have seen all stranger things I think
you I think he can really kick ass that
was a tomboy you know yeah I feel like
he can bring something different I like
what they're saying between the walking
the razor's edge between horror and
comic book movies I love that yes
appealing line I've heard out of any of
these announcements actually and that's
the thing is like that as much as yeah I
just feel split it's like half of me
wants to see how boy conclude because
like it seems like a shame to - all that
passion
oh it's over and even even the people
who say like yeah it's not really the
comic book Guillermo del Toro's so
brought something to it that I think
people do accept about it and you said
with the practical creatures and the
practical makeups I don't think they can
really get away with dialing back too
hard on that because that Satan del Toro
brought that I think everybody kind of
yeah it is just kind of like yeah that
should be a part oh you know like that
would be if I see a trailer and I see no
practical effect in a bunch of crazy CGI
yeah I'm gonna be kind of upset yeah I
would be too
you can do it with any mood okay even
when you see the been her third remake
and you're like ah it's all CGI Brendon
because they already did it for real
yeah exactly
she don't like her well this baby like
Freddy come out on the wall I'm like I
saw this when it when I could see it
from yeah it is it is a setting I mean
and I kind of worried the studio would
go well guys we're rebooting this partly
because the Hellboy movies didn't make
as much money as we wanted this isn't an
art project for yeah so we're going to
me to do CGI save some money here in
Apple's everyone had a motion capture
and it smell that yeah yeah but
excepting you know accepting the news
there will not be another run Perlman
Hellboy and hearing this new news I'm
like this sounds like an awesome idea
like I really like the idea of this I
like the attitude they have I want to
make it r-rated which is cool which is
awesome and I think Neil Marshall is a
great choice for something like this and
I think that could also give him a
chance to show again I haven't seen
everything he's done but I think this
could give him a chance to really bring
a new visual flair yet his work and some
new tones his palate you know like it's
a cool opportunity 'ls with I mean yeah
there's a lot of elements in it that can
garner a worthy are rating more than
just who were violent like there it can
be a much darker much more sinister tone
throughout because it deals with
collecting all cowboy how big like a
deep
hey hey Curtis 50 cent Jackson just
landed a role in the Avatar French
that's about time he got into smoke caps
a clip Curtis who you might know from a
lot of films and just go check em out on
IMDB he actually does it I saw a video
on YouTube was like a bunch of roles
Clippers wouldn't it look can I just
like a Gary Oldman yeah so many things I
don't even realize that Curtis man he
deserves more love can do voices body
language like he can do it all but
Curtis is great but he plays a normal
American father there's a lotta
character that when I was watching that
show the only reason I I don't think I
like that character so much as I wanted
to like him because it was my cooker
yeah he's going to be in the Avatar
franchise playing a character named
total worry
the leader of the mythic Ayana reef who
will apparently play a major role in the
story arc for the next four avatar film
oh man the reef people are coming now
I'm not going to try to speculate at all
but who the hell he's playing I'm sure
what we're gonna care about the next
avatar films is how cool or special
effects are we'll see yeah we'll see I
don't think anyone's excited about
revisiting Pandora I don't even think
people care about their damn theme park
do what they should do is they should
have Ridley Scott and they should have a
James Cameron switch everyone be cool so
have James Cameron go direct whatever
the sequel come on I really sky go
direct the next avatar movie because
think about it then he can do all that
philosophical drug that he's been
wanting to to pursue making avatar
actually enjoyable I think I could
Kurtis will probably be killed off of
fear The Walking Dead one of the few
characters of fear The Walking Dead who
actually has an action figure
really you got a Wondrich on you Phil
he's walking yet action figures they're
like oh you got like two characters from
fear the lung good guess cliff Curtis
and cliff Curtis is like yeah
well cliff Curtis is one of the few good
things about fear the walking dead to me
okay I I don't really enjoy that show to
be honest I'll level with you guys I
only watched the first couple seasons
because I knew one of the cast members
we both do Lorenzo James Henry and after
he was killed off that was so spoiler
that was put out everywhere on the
internet so I feel if you if you were
planning on watching the show and I just
ruined it for you like you know I'm just
not invested enough to really want to
continue the show anymore I started
watching it it was hard to get hooked on
it's a hard show to get um but dude I've
often heard people describe your The
Walking Dead is the show that you watch
because you watch the walk it is it is
filler
now the reef people are supposed to play
a major arc in the next for avatar funk
whoo that doesn't mean cliff curtis's
character will be in the next for avatar
films he probably had to sign some
mysterious contract that says that did
you well if James Cameron wants it to be
in the next for avatar film I'm just
thinking though that the walking fair
log hands been picked up for like a
couple more seasons I I don't know I
just can't imagine Cliff Curtis having
the time to do all this yeah I feel like
and I feel like if he's going to make a
choice he's gonna ask to be killed after
The Walking Dead over leaving a James
Cameron avatar project uh yeah I mean it
seems like you just have the whole world
at your feet when you yeah on the the
Cameron train I mean I feel like you'd
have all he probably has more emotional
depth to do with fear The Walking Dead
considering his character's a father and
all this other stuff
living in the apocalypse he's the main
character and a TV show however sucking
James Cameron yeah I don't even like
avatar but if James Cameron wanted me in
his bike next three films I'd be like
I'll let every to honor James can't
afford it
you're the guy you almost there's a
channel or the resale do
ever you want yeah did that ever
reported is what I want a friendship
with you
we're as well learn here knowledge yeah
I just want to be m7u and plan on how
much of a dick you really are on set I
just want to leave some taste you know I
want to eat some tapes and write about
you my autobiography or my careers
really get the down-low
cuz he James Cameron is the most lady I
don't know I think Arnold's the only one
who kissable opportunist Cameron because
you kind of addictive yes I can see you
can see whatever but not I mean so many
people talk [ __ ] I'm like why they just
won't work with James Cameron again yeah
yeah it's a corny we like I think it's
going to be very normal they're just
naturally two very tough people
yeah but I feel like can put up with
James can be type of activity consider I
and probably know exactly how to talk
yeah you know I mean they can't all be
true because like Bill Paxton work with
him so many times
yeah and you know they that were
together so many times and and Arnold's
worth in several times and Sigourney
Weaver now is multiple times I'd imagine
he's a great person to work with but hey
we've acted with Curtis yeah I think
you're gonna get killed off here The
Walking Dead the only reason why I
pulled up this story for us to talk
about boy because I'm gonna do now
otherwise you mean come on man yeah I
feel bad for you if you're doing both
you should have a personal one you're so
now I don't like it why do you care
about it being on set all day have a
personal life live you gotta make it
enough on the login' alright like shadow
took it your chef Spiller for another
show that people aren't really like
anymore go join the avatar movies and
one is sitting behind fear The Walking
Dead what if this is like some weird
moment where fear The Walking Dead is
about to get great about he does about
just starts like well they are if you're
The Walking Dead they are like replacing
the head writers and stuff alright you
know the showrunners something The
Walking Dead know
to do implement our yeah
alright let's say this is it hiring a
director for a few movie guys you keep
changing the main people new budget John
our know if you know about this next
door but I think you should read it out
loud guys did you know that a new
Deadpool animated series is in
development at PHA FXX can't go read the
rest oh man here we go
Atlanta creators executive producers
Donald Glover and Stephen Glover or
Stefan Glover if he prefers it that way
will be a spearheading this Deadpool
animated series that showrunners
executive producers and right are you
excited my I know you're in Atlanta fan
I love Atlanta yeah I'm a big fan of
Donald Glover and I'm but I am also a
fan of Stephen glove a good life
I like that guys who are fast as a
Deadpool I think out of any of the
characters that are currently popular in
like movie standards of comic book world
death was the only one that truly makes
sense right now like all uncle work is
animated but we've all seen animated
versions a lot of it already I think
that people would still be enjoyable
isn't it yeah Deadpool I think would
work perfectly because the movie itself
is out of all them it's like the closest
to a cartoon yeah
Teli um even more so than like guardians
of the galaxy because the garbha galaxy
is very like animated the levels are
different yeah the rules the Deadpool
you world board works so well as an FX
show and I'm not familiar with Donald
Glover as you are but I know how much
you love him and how much the world
loves to homo Glover right now well I
think this is a cool opportunity because
a it's like you know he didn't get to
play spider-man but he's still you know
gang dispirit superhero project and I
think it's cool that he gets to go back
to something that's probably gonna be
more overtly comedic over and something
that it also is going to have only comic
book [ __ ] yeah
as far as FX has their Legion show which
I'm sure this death will show will be
very similar in tone and style to cook
it but hey I mean like I think what FX
doing with this stuff is really cool and
and like you know Atlanta gets like
absurd at times and strange and you know
very forgetful yeah so like I think just
this is a cool opportunity to see a
different side like I'm a little
surprised that they're getting it but
I'm super excited to that's the case
well hey you get the black touch for
Deadpool now plus like you got to
imagine the movie and the cartoon will
probably touch each other yeah you know
I bet that's what I'm hoping for yeah I
feel like Ryan Reynolds would have no
problem making my parents on the devil
an efficient engine vice versa like I'm
sure these are going to be my odds of
seeing any of the Avengers being like
sure we'll make a cameo and one of your
Netflix shows it seems a lot less likely
to me than Ryan Reynolds being like yeah
I do that somebody that didn't like Alec
Baldwin on this analysis I'm sure yeah I
feel like I feel like he would
absolutely love to be a part of that
yeah but I don't know who did a voice to
do Deadpool I don't know if it's like
them that says dog lovers going to be
one of the show runners and riders for
the show and producer so it's going to
have a lot of the behind the scenes
control I don't know who's going to be
voicing Deadpool yeah but a Deadpool
animated series yeah it sounds perfect I
would gladly watch an animated series
except you couldn't do it before but FX
has the capability and let me what's FXX
I don't know the exact deal with what
that channel is but it's you know it's
from FX yeah obviously but FX I know has
gets away with a lot of violence it
where words but you know they don't say
it didn't see the airport I don't know I
was gonna say wonder okay had the F word
in it right or their incomes difference
for your episodes really said the F word
that we were like whoa you could say the
F word on a things apparently yeah well
technically you can it's just about the
advertisers and what they'll allow you
know but yeah yeah yeah I think
theoretically you can I don't know if
FXX is like a more like after dark or
like yeah your version FXX has it's
always sunny now okay
so and I'm going to say Archer what's
what's what's this
and practices on Archer yeah these are
they're all definitely r-rated material
yeah it's just that kind of be like this
is a couple of things you will be do you
see this little in the show no nipples
I'm curious because yet watching the
People vs OJ it seemed like they were
willing to flex the boundary you can see
men's asses significantly more and even
a woman's ass way more than you will see
a single boob nip yes you can see who
hole on graphic sex scenes in American
Horror Story as long as you don't see a
nipple here
oh [ __ ] meet Lisa yeah you don't see a
nipple Atty you do a whole boob within
the shadows it's slightly blocking out
with it oh you're all right did you know
the girl will be riding a guy's dick
really fast and hard get a behind shot
that as long as he has sheets on Matty
because of the shadows that are blocking
it out here okay hair is in the right
place yeah then we can get away with it
yeah do it doughnut lover Deadpool all
right I'm excited for it that means to
me the movie news this week hasn't
exactly been the most thrilling but it's
all stuff I take an interest in into
it's good to gather the information on
it oh yeah anyway guys a question for
you peeps I don't have a question what
the hell are we app what's your favorite
type of pie what's your favorite type of
pie
what'd you get your mom for Mother's
don't you get your mom for Mother's Day
what should we get our moms for Mother's
Day I got my mom a dick in a box whose
mine tinkin no she's not going to fall
in love with another man I'm my mom's
only man oh well I mean I can't use my
dick how's that working out I'm just
saying mom this belongs to you my my
entire masculinity is yeah yeah an
ornament for your mental she gave me my
penis and now I'm giving it back so it
came from her
even though you scriber the real rejects
John three Jerry
no no longer that John Humphrey if
you're watching this on patreon
we'll do some special moves for you
because it's not only audio it's not
only audio no patrons video I had sex
with my cast that's where I got these
scratches from tenth it's all kinds of
things it cannot be understood this is
just one of our weird as deliveries this
has never done video what happens when
we film this on Mother's Day
yeah Sunday's are those Sunday's to the
we're done days are the foggy head day
that's where we worked all week
Saturday's the day we usually they're
like let's go have a little bit of fun
now because we've been busy hokey and
then we sleep in it like all right we're
getting back there you things and then
sunday is like everything's a little
hotter than ever and we definitely are
gonna groove but yeah what's that see
you guys and check out our merch check
it